for first though ten police officers
were injured and 14 people have been
arrested after a black lives matter
protest in London which had been
peaceful for most of the day
now the anti-racism marched follow the
death of George Floyd in Minneapolis
after a police officer knelt on his neck
which has sparked almost two weeks of
demonstrations across the United States
well we can go now to central London and
talk to the House Secretary Matt Hancock
thank you for being on the program
this morning and I just want to start
with those protests because it does feel
like the death of George florid has
sparked a lot of soul-searching in the
United Kingdom as well do you think that
this country is racist I don't but I do
think that there's injustice that needs
to be tackled and I've spent my
political life fighting for equality and
for diversity and I think that you know
I think we're one of the most tolerant
and open societies in the world but
there's always more that can and must be
done especially to empower people so
that they can they can achieve their
potential that's at the it's at the core
of my political beliefs and I think that
it's incredibly important so I think
that there is I think the substance of
what's being said and they and their and
the arguments made by those who are
marching I think there's a lot to it I
think thankfully this is all based in
response to events in America rather
than here but we also must continue the
drive here for tolerance and genuine
equality of opportunity it's interesting
you say that more should be done chiming
really with what's at a Javid who until
a few months ago was sitting around the
cabinet table with you has said in the
Sunday Times saying that ethnic
minorities in Britain are still the
victims of racial injustice and suspense
substantial disparities an opportunity
the government can and must do more to
address racial inequalities in our
society so specifically what should the
government do well I think the it's
right across the board that actions
actions needed it's a core part of the
leveling up agenda that this government
is committed to it of course
starts with education and job
opportunities you know so it's right
across the board and in my area in
health we see health disparities as well
that need to be need to be addressed and
we see disparities in for instance even
before Kovac disparities in life
expectancy and then this disease is
cruelly demonstrated that there's more
of an impact on people from black and
minority ethnic backgrounds as well so I
think it's something that is important
that we all drive forward on because a
truly fair society is one where there's
equality of opportunity and that means
giving opportunities you know I
absolutely Col of my political beliefs
is that every single person has a
contribution to make and something to
offer and it's the responsibility of the
state to help them to make the most of
that of that contribution just to pick
up on what you were saying there about
how black and minority ethnic
communities took greater risk of dying
from cave in 19 than white people
because this week and public health
England published that report but it
didn't actually include any
recommendations for action were those
recommendations held back no there's a
whole series of changes that we've
already made and the next step which
we're taking forward across government
and being led by camy bad knock the
Minister for equalities is to make sure
we get to the bottom of the question why
are those disparities there and what
further steps can we can we take for
instance some of the explanation may be
down to a higher likelihood of people
from black and minority ethnic
backgrounds being in occupations where
the occupation is more at risk and for
instance frontline occupations both in
transport and and in health service and
social care and putting more protection
in place for people in those occupations
will in turn help reduce these
disparities so that's the work that
we're now taking forward following on
from the report that you that you
mentioned we've been talking about the
importance of doing more and
how many black people are on cabinet I'm
so sorry I didn't catch that question
Sophie how many black people are in the
current cabinet the well we've good
there's a whole series of people from a
black and minority ethnic background the
chance they extract
the Home Secretary is to name part two
so I'm talking about black people
specifically because I do think it's
quite important not to lump everyone
from non-white backgrounds together
because obviously Asian people for
example face prejudice too but it might
be different prejudice to that face by
black people
62 percent for example GCSE pupils from
Indian backgrounds got a strong paths in
English and maths 27% of Black Caribbean
you're three times as likely to be
stopped and searched if you're black and
if you're Asian so that's why I was
specifically asking about how many black
people there are in the current cabinet
well the cabinet's that I've the two
cabinets I've sat in with Boris Johnson
as Prime Minister are the two most
diverse cabinets I've ever sat in and
you know right at the top of Godman
including in the great offices of state
people from black and minority ethnic
backgrounds quasi parting was sitting
around the cabinet table with me and so
actually I think that but well I think
that Boris Johnson has got a very good
record on this and it brings people in
and listens to a diversity of views and
its diversity of thought that's the
really important thing when you're
taking those big decisions around the
cabinet table are you saying that people
from black backgrounds shouldn't really
worry that there aren't any there isn't
a single person from a black background
at the current cabinet table because you
have diversity of thought no what I'm
saying is that the the cabinet's the
government's that Boris Johnson leads us
are some of the most diverse in the
history of this country I just was
talking about the Minister for
equalities chemi about not who's taking
forward this work
she's just she joined the government
recently and been brought in by Boris
Johnson and it's that diversity of
thought is absolutely critical and
incredibly important for making good
decisions but there's a there's a
broader point which is making sure we
address this whole issue and make sure
that we increase the chances and
increase the opportunities for everybody
and in doing that for everybody so of
course we must do it for those who are
the most disadvantaged or whatever the
color of their skin and it happens that
the we've got to make sure in particular
that this agenda leads to closing gaps
in inequalities including inequalities
between people of different ethnic
backgrounds so you know it is a broad
agenda that the government is pursuing
and pushing very very hard what I would
say is the way to achieve this is to
make the argument and I support that
argument very strongly and that but
please don't gather in groups of more
than six people because there is also a
pandemic that we must address and
control and so there is we've got to
make the argument we've got to make
further progress on top of the
significant progress that has been made
in recent years and we've but we've got
to do it in a way that's safe and
controls the virus on that now it's
talking about not gathering in groups of
more than six and of course you can have
deep sympathy with the aims the protests
that we've seen this week but also have
concerns about the number of people
gathering in a pandemic do you think
that seeing the number of people that we
did gathering in groups means that an
increase in cases of covert 19 is now
more likely
well it's undoubtedly a risk it's
undoubtedly risks so you know I support
very strongly the argument that is being
made by those who are protesting for
more equality and and against
discrimination but the virus itself
doesn't discriminate and gathering in
large groups is temporarily against the
rules precisely because it increases the
risk of the spread of this virus so I
would urge people to make their argument
and I will I will support you in making
that argument but please don't spread
the this virus which has already done so
much damage in which we're starting to
get under control I'm keen to move on
now to the government's response to a
corona virus in Quebec 19 because the
Sunday Times is reporting this morning
that Boris Johnson has ordered ministers
to start lifting the lockdown more
quickly in order to save up to 3.5
million jobs and those new measures
signed off at a meeting with the
Chancellor on Friday night II is that
correct
we've got a clear plan and we're working
through that plan that plan does involve
the reopening and subject to ensuring
that it's safe the reopening of the
remaining retail that isn't currently
open in a week's time and I know you're
addressing that later on this on the
program and we're working through that
plan and the plan and the strategy
hasn't changed it's a matter of working
through it and of course always always
doing that with safety front of mind
cautiously progressing now we are making
significant progress against this virus
we protected the NHS and we've bent the
curve down so there's fewer and fewer
new cases and that is a good thing but
we've got to get that number of new
cases right down so that it is safe and
then we're going to hold it down both
through being very cautious on the on
the national lockdown measures and also
of course introducing more local action
to be able to deal with local flare-ups
when we find them you are emphasizing
how important is to have a safety-first
approach to it and you've always said
along with a prime minister that you'll
be guided by the science and the our
rate the rate of infection is something
that you've talked about a lot the need
to keep that below 1
but starting out this week a model from
Cambridge University in public health
England said that our has risen in all
regions and its above one in some
regions and that these increases may
result in the decline in the national
death rate being arrested by mid June if
that is the case then why are you
pushing ahead with easing the lockdown
yeah who will be the the straightforward
answer to that is that we take into
account a number of models just over
there are several models that we take
into account through sage sage brings
that advice together you mentioned one
model and the same day that was
published a more direct measurement
through the Office of National
Statistics showed that note the number
of new cases per day had fallen from
around 8,000 to around five and a half
thousand which obviously we're talking
about are because you are the ones who
put that at the heart of your response
Yeah right so I was just going to come
onto that absolutely so my point is what
you shouldn't do is look at one
particular report and say that is the
answer and you should look right across
the board at all of the different
measures that are taken into account and
the scientists bring this together
through Sage and sages overall view is
that R is between point seven and point
nine and that it is below one in each
region of the country but you're right
Sophie that there are some areas where
we think R is a bit higher than
elsewhere including the North West of
England and and we've got to make sure
that where there are localized outbreaks
we absolutely tackle those working with
local directors of Public Health and so
this is an important part of how we do
how we tackle the next phase which is
where there's a local outbreak we take a
local action
I spoke to Andy Burnham for instance the
mayor of Greater Manchester because of
the increased prevalence of problems it
relative to the rest of the country
in the northwest but overall are remains
below one between 0.7 and 0.9
by the best estimate of sage including
in all parts of the country so we are
able to proceed but again I come back to
this and I will keep going back to this
we we proceed with caution and we
proceed with safety first making sure
that as those shops do reopen and that
it is safe to do so and they do so in a
way that's compliant with the The Cove
it's safe working guidelines I take your
point and that you can't just pick up
one study you have to look at models
across the board so where are we
currently on the covert alert system
that your government introduced well
we're currently on level four and moving
towards level three and I look forward
to an update on that as and when we get
more and more data in because the reason
I'm asking is that when you brought in
the covert alert system the government
showed some slides at the daily press
conference and those slides clearly
stated that an easing of lockdown
restrictions only begins at level three
so I'm going to skip it confused why is
it that we are beginning the gradual
relaxed tone of restrictions and social
distancing measures while we're still at
level four well where as you say we're
guided by the science throughout this
that's incredibly important and the
chief medical officer the chief
scientific adviser who bring together
all of that scientific advice because
you know there's a hundred voices on
Sage and each of them makes their points
to the best of their scientific ability
and understanding and then that's
brought together by the chief medical
officer and the chief scientific adviser
they advisors and we as ministers
democratically elected make the
decisions that's how it works and the
the level is clearly moving from four to
three and the reason for that is because
we can see that the number of new
infections is coming down it's it's now
a long long way below where it was at
the peak it's below where it was well
it's been coming down all the way
through and sadly there are still people
dying but the number of people
each day is also falling the number of
people admitted to hospital is falling
the number of people in hospital is
falling so we are winning the battle
against this disease and that allows us
to release more of the restrictions
including putting in place this local
action supported by the test and tray
system but we've got to be cautious in
our approach to it because the last
thing anybody wants is for the virus to
get going again and does have to go
right back to square one you see I just
slightly confused as to why you'd
introduce a covert alert level system
and then just not follow it and you know
we've been told time and time again that
we're following the science but the our
rate doesn't seem to be coming down it
seems to be ticking up if anything the
alert level hasn't come down from level
4 to level 3 but we're still pressing on
with easing the lockdown now I
understand that there will be economic
concerns as well genuine economic
concerns too but I just don't really
wouldn't just admit that those concerns
are coming into play as well and you're
not necessarily still following the
science well because I'm not going to
say that because that's not true you see
the thing is you have to take into
account all considerations not just pick
on a couple so for instance the point
about our is that when our is below 1
the number of new infections continues
to fall our is about the rate of change
of infections not about the the level
and so that's why keeping our below 1 is
so important because you don't want the
virus to go out of control but it also
means that where it wherever R is below
1 that will keep the number of
infections down and falling so the
assessment of our being below 1 is
important and if R moves towards 1 but
stays below 1 then the rating with which
the number of new infections comes down
will slow but the number of new
infections will continue to come down
you know this difference between the
level and the rate of change is
absolutely critical to understanding how
we control this this virus and the
result of that
is that the approach we're taking taking
into account all of the different models
all of the epidemiology and all of the
scientific advice which is so important
for us to base our decisions on is that
we're taking a cautious approach now
people do ask me about the economy but
my view is that the worst thing for the
economy would be a second spike and so
there isn't this trade-off that is you
know much is made of in the in the media
between the health and the economy I
care deeply about getting the economy
going and the best way to get the
economy going is to is to ensure that we
get the number of new infections right
down that's what matters for the future
of the economy as well so it's not a
it's easy to write stories about a trade
off what really matters what really
matters for this whole country is that
we get the number of infections right
down we keep that are at below one and
then and then we can cautiously
cautiously reopen some of the things
that everybody that you know some of the
things that make life worth living
whether that's on the economic side or
indeed allowing people to to meet in
groups of up to six all this more of the
announcement from the community
secretary this morning that private
prayer is now going to be allowed which
i think is an incredibly important and
positive step for many many people we
are running out of time but just quickly
of course this quarantine is coming into
place from tomorrow where any arrivals
and the UK will have to itself isolate
for two weeks it's at the end of the
summer holiday abroad for this year at
least
well we're bringing in the quarantine
policy again because as the number of
new infections comes down so the
proportion of infections that come from
abroad increases simply because the
number of infections new infections
domestically it is coming right down you
know I've said before I really hope that
we're going people are going to be able
to fly to go on summer holiday but we've
got to we've got to take a an approach
that starts with caution of course we do
okay Matthew Hancock thank you very much
for being on the program this morning
thank you